I wish I liked the video but my first
solo song little boy was your love so
they say I like the video by the song I
was like why do that you heard it right
Nicki Minaj wishes she never recorded
some of her biggest hits the chun-li
rapper opened up about her regrets at
the Polestar live conference which fans
were able to catch on her hairstylist :
Derek's Instagram live at the conference
Nicki also revealed the one song she
wished she could have collaborated with
Beyonce on
[Music]
nikki is attempting to say bye to all
the drama in her life after making
headlines for her back and forth with ex
Meek Mill will maybe disappear the
rapper's haven't been on good terms
since they split in 2017 after two years
of dating but this week things escalated
to a different level after they both
tweeted serious allegations against one
another
Nikki accusing Meek Mill of physical
abuse which he denies and meek Mill
letting it be known that when his album
drops he will not let his interviews be
filled with questions about quote her he
goes on to say no Devils tricks TMZ
reported last month that the
philadelphia rapper and Nicki Minaj's
husband Kenneth petty got into a
shouting match when the three ran into
each other at a clothing store in West
Hollywood
Nikki referencing that incident in this
tweet on Wednesday on paper the Barbie
dreams rapper has officially moved on
confirming she tied the knot with
Kenneth petty back in October the two
have yet to have a big ceremony and
Nikki explains to ET that there's a good
reason behind it but it was so crazy
when I was little I always imagined you
know Princess Anne and marriage and
wedding the wedding and now it's more to
me about the life the future the love
the partnership then the wedding which
is so strange because I didn't expect
myself to be one of those people who
didn't care about the hoopla but I
really don't and he was asking me today
too he was like so you know what are we
gonna do it like cuz you keep on you
know I'm like oh yeah I'm like I just I
just kind of feel like it doesn't mean
as much as it used to mean because the
other part the real part I haven't
I'm so happy but that happens when
you're with the right person thank you
[Music]